hi guys it's now evening time here we're
about seven hours ahead in Thailand
I mean bouquet at the let Mary DN hotel
so I thought I'll just give you a quick
tour of the outside because it is
fantastic so where I'm standing right
now is the beach this is the beach in
the evening time as you can see it's
absolutely fantastic it's really clear
warm and actually that the beach is here
but the outdoor pool which kind of
circles all around the hotel is just
here so this is the pool and the pool
really is massive I mean this is
probably just about maybe a quarter of
of the actual pool but it goes all
around the outside around the hotel the
restaurants are fabulous it really is
just real paradise kind of place so I'm
the reason I'm here in Thailand is I'm
actually only on a course I'm going on a
program which is which is a five-day
program some 105 days studying five days
relaxing and then by the time I come
back to England I'm going to be ready to
really give and give out so yeah I mean
that's kind of the idea here anyway come
study meditate relax and learn and then
come back and pull it all into practice
and make a real difference in the world
just fabulous
okay this is a little bit of a better
angle these are the restaurants so you
can while you're eating your evening
dinner and your breakfast you can see
the pool and you can see the ocean as
well
which is beautiful I know which one I
like better the ocean that the oceans
did God pool and then this was the man
called ocean every time this is the
other section of the pool so you can
kind of swim all around the restaurants
and all around the hotel but there's
literally everything you could really
want along here all the hairdresser's
souvenir shops clothes shops here we
have the jam I'm not sure how much time
I'll be spending there hopefully some
time so this is the entrance or valet
parking and everything like that success
breeds success very true
and there was give you a real wall
entrance when when we arrived they
rushed over to give us flowers and wine
this is part of the entrance which is
all very ground the filming doesn't
really do it just this so I really why
am I here well yes I like a little bit
of luxury but it's really for the
training for the time to think I mean if
you want to help people and you want to
make a difference in the world you need
to first invest in yourself just for
this trip in Thailand just for the
ticket alone not including the hotel the
flights or food which of course is very
expensive but just for the ticket alone
five day ticket was twelve thousand
pounds there's some people think wow
that's an awful lot of money but if
you're not prepared to invest in
yourself how can you then invest in
other people which is what I'm all about
when people say you know I might put on
a training course which is a few hundred
pounds and they say sounds a bit
expensive and it's like I've just paid
you know twenty thousand pounds for it
yet it really just shows you know hit
the mindset of some people but if you're
not prepared to but high value on
yourself then game over you might as
well stop it stop now most people say to
me they say Sami what I physically
couldn't afford to go on and start going
on courses and things like that you know
it's really a mindset thing because
maybe if you went on the course then you
be able to afford them because the more
you learn the more you earn
but anyway Rance over time for me to get
drenched go get some dinner and get too
bad so wherever you are in the world
have a fantastic day bless you all